دائره الشرطه هذا البناء واعتقلت امراه
سوريه ترمت لاحقا بزرع القنبله في شارع
الاستقلال وكانت تنوي الهربه الى اليونان
وفقا روايات السلطات التركيه
فور الكشف عن اسم منفذه التفجير وهي احلام
البشير اتجهت الانظار الى هذا الحي وهو حي
كناريا في منطقه
حيث القت الشرطه القبض عليها هنا
زرنا بعض محال الحي وسالنا اصحابها
والجيران عن احلام والاشخاص الذين سكنوا
البيت هل راوهم من قبل وهل كان لهم ظهور
علوي او معارف جواب الجميع كان انهم لا
يعرفونهم وفوجهوا بوجودهم في الحي
الاشخاص من قبل
هنا
قالوا انهم كانوا يسكنون قبل منزلين او
ثلاثه
صراحه لم اشاهده من قبل لم ياتوا الى
دكاني حتى سكان الحي القدامى لم يتعرفوا
على قاطن المنزل الذي داهمته الشرطه
ويرجحون انهم سكنوا المنزله قبل الحادثه
بايام فقط
الحج وبدات عمليات التفتيش احزاننا هذا
الشيء فتشوا كل المنازل حتى الجامعه لم
نرى هذه العائله منذ قبل لم نتخيل ان يكون
هؤلاء الاشخاص بيننا كثيرون منا حزين
وشعروا بالقلق لا نتمنى ان يتكرر هذا
الشيء
الشرطه التركيه نشرت الاربعاء فيديو جديده
يظهر وصول احلام البشير الى شارع
الاستقلال وجلوسها على احد المقاعد ثم
مغادرتها تاركه حقيبه على الكرسي وسط
الشارع وفرارها بعد انفجار القنبله زيدان
زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول